bonjour à vous deux merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de débattre ce matin sur
rtl france il ya cinq candidats donc
pour cette primaire écolo dont le
premier tour aura lieu du 16 au 19
septembre on va revenir sur le tweet de
yannick jadot avec vous si vous le
voulez bien jacques boutault il a parlé
de radicalité de l'écologie et de règles
à imposer ça a plutôt fait réagir qu'en
pensez vous ou est ce que c'était les
bons termes
l'écologie est un principe radical dans
la mesure où elle vaut changer nos
façons de concevoir nos rapports avec
notre rapport à l'économie en
particulier et de penser la société
autrement et donc cette radicalité elle
passe par les urnes mais il faut
comprendre de mouradi qualité à son sens
premier du terme c'est à dire on
travaille les problèmes à la racine la
radicalité c'est la racine et c'est bien
tout ce qui est en train de le pousser
dans notre société qu'il faut qu'il faut
modifier pour une société plus apaisé
une société dans laquelle chacune et
chacun ait sa place et non pas une
société la concurrence et du tous contre
chacun qui met la planète en péril avec
le productivisme et la course sans fin
au profit qui est génératrice on le sait
de la majorité des attaques contre la
biodiversité et qui met aujourd'hui en
péril notre civilisation même par la
production de ce ces de ces gaz à effet
de serre induites par une économie sans
frein sans direction sans tête est ce
que veut dire yannick jadot c'est qu'il
faut de la régulation dans l'économie il
faut que ce soit les citoyens eux mêmes
qui décident de ce qui est bon pour eux
mêmes et non pas ce qui est bon pour les
profits et et pour ceux qui veulent
s'enrichir perpétuellement afin de
continuer les principes de domination à
la fois sur les êtres humains et à la
fois sur les animaux la planète et la
biodiversité d'être qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est ça la radicalité
écologie merci pour cette précision on
va continuer de parler d'eux ces mesures
et de cette primaire écolo et de la
gauche également qu'ils portent
certaines idées écologistes on va le
voir avec la maire de paris notamment
revenons-en à vous stéphane ravier vous
êtes invités parce que les anti écolo
vont-ils déstabiliser la primaire
l'assistant parlementaire européen du
rassemblement national s'est inscrit
mardi dernier à la primaire d'europe
écologie les verts et il affirme qu'il
votera s'il le peut pour sandrine
rousseau qui selon lui montre le vrai
visage on voit son tweet à l'écran un
commentaire stéphane rallié sur ce twitt
la coupe de france cette candidature
c'est la candidature notre ami dernier
rieuse et ça oui c'est à mairieux qui
s'est inscrit pour participer à la
primaire des verts dans dix jours la
primaire des écologistes dans dix jours
oui on va écouter ce soir c'est son
droit c'est son droit de le faire et on
verra si la
radicalité démocratique qui est qui a
été affirmé ici ce matin or l'un des
représentants ouvert sera sera accepté
notre ami fait mon ami en tout cas
d'annie rieux sera démontré que derrière
la communication écologique se cache en
réalité une idéologie une idéologie
écologistes qui est plus plus enclins à
lutter pour une immigration débridée une
migration invasion que pour sauver que
pour sauver la planète donc pourquoi pas
papa une un débat au sein de scène de la
nébuleuse verte de militants nationale
qui lui lui représente la protection
aurait rien de l'environnement par la
maîtrise des flux migratoires
car la
déferlante migratoire
on souhaite les verts constituent en
réalité un danger danger réel pour
l'équilibré écologique votre réaction
jacques boutault
la première réaction c'est de dire que
le rassemblement national est tellement
peu habitué à la démocratie au loup au
choix
libre de son candidat que dès qu'un
parti le fait ils ne pensent qu à
tricher a bidonné donc c'est quand même
révélateur d'un état d'esprit parce que
je vous rappelle que pour voter pour
cette primaire il faut signer une charte
dans laquelle on adhère aux valeurs de
l'écologie bon en même temps c'est un
peu picrocholines aujourd'hui avant le
débat il y avait 35 mille inscrits il y
en aura probablement le double à la fin
il inscrit je voulais justement vous
interrogé là-dessus 35000 inscrit ses
essais au dessous de vos espérances me
dire c'est la première fois que les
écologistes organiser les primaires
ouvertes donc c'était difficile de
mettre une jauge effectivement pour
l'instant faut reconnaître qu'on a très
peu parlé de ce débat il ya peu et merci
de le faire mais avant l'organisation du
débat coude entendu hier les les médias
ont très peu parlé de cette primaire
donc je pense que le fait qu on en parle
tous les média à attirer de nouvelles de
personnes qui vont avoir envie ne serait
ce parce qu'elles disposent de
l'information de pouvoir s'y engager et
tu la deuxième chose que je voulais
répondre à mon interlocuteur c'est que
aujourd'hui les flux migratoires mots
qui parlent qui sont pas massif il
existe certes mais qui sont pas massif
ils sont liées en premier lieu aux
dérèglements climatiques au fait que les
populations dans les pays acp migrants
sont l'objet de pressions liées à la
raréfaction des ressources aux
dérèglements climatiques à la sécheresse
aux inondations ou mal de livres ils
sont directement liés au dérèglement
climatique et au mode de vie ailleurs
principalement de nous occidentaux qui
en émettant des gaz à effet de serre
contribuent au mal de vivre des
populations du sud donc commençons par
travailler le problème à la racine
soyons radicales comme je le disais au
sens éthique et travaillons sur les
causes du dérèglement climatique pour
permettre aux gens de rester chez eux
savez on ne migrent pas par plaisir à
ainsi on et mears et qui a plus d'autre
solution notre survie c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
encore une fois en reprenant en main les
questions environnementales
on réglera en partie a tout de suite les
questions de migration ses fans ralliez
vous êtes d'accord avec celle l occident
a sa part de responsabilité dans
l'immigration à cause du climat
c'est c'est évidemment la technique et
des verts en particulier mais dans
l'ensemble classe politique en général
et surtout à gauche que de culpabiliser
les français en particulier les
européens en général autrefois à cp
notre présence il fut un temps dans ces
pays pour est qui qui est pour lequel
nous devrions nous excuser en permanence
ses excuses ensemble par le devoir
d'accueillir ces populations aujourd'hui
la nouvelle culpabilisation c'est le
dérèglement climatique nous serions
responsables du dérèglement climatique
alors que la france en particulier est
l'un des meilleurs élèves en matière de
rejets de gaz à effet de serre que le
mauvais élève le très mauvais élèves
c'est la chine la chine en 2018 qui a
été le pays qui a un rôle qui a rejeté
des gaz à effet de serre au delà de tout
ce que les autres pays occidentaux ont
pu n ont pu rejeter mais les verts en
france ne demande pas à la chine
d'accepter d'accueillir d'aider ces
réfugiés climatiques il ne manque pas
non plus à l'inde au pakistan ou même
aux états unis qui sont les principaux
fournisseurs de gaz à effet de serre on
culpabilise les français parce que l'on
a décidé de changer radicalement
radicalement pour le tour le coup la
composition de notre de notre société de
notre pays en en faisant un pays je
dirais multiculturelle mais un pays
multiculturel on le voit aujourd'hui
c'est un pays multi conflictuelles et ça
les verts on vient d'entendre qu'il
faudrait régler les problèmes dans ces
pays
ce rachat d'air mais en réalité les
verts demandent l'accueil est non
seulement des étrangers de c c
de ces pseudo réfugiés demande aussi la
régularisation de tous les clandestins
oh ça constitue évidemment un appel
d'air à une nouvelle génération
on demande aussi la légalisation du
cannabis c'est un renversement de
société à laquelle les l'air sont
attachés et pas simplement de sauver les
géraniums ou quelques arbres pour le
bien-être de l'ensemble de la population
c'est vraiment un modèle société qui
passe par une immigration massive bien
et je me régale même pointé du doigt
cette contradiction les verts sont
attachés au libre échange à la
mondialisation c'est-à-dire les échanges
des biens et des personnes ce qui
constitue un déséquilibre écologique
flagrant que les que les herbes souhaite
pas remettre en cause chaque bouton
réaction non mais là il ya une erreur
d'analysé colossal dès le départ de la
part de mon interlocuteur c'est que il
dit que la france produit peu de gaz à
effet de serre et que la chine en
produit beaucoup mais eux c'est normal
puisque la chine produit 85 % voire plus
des biens manufacturés que nous
utilisons que nous utilisons en france
qui sont produits en chine et donc la
france si on y intègre la pollution
importer le gaz à effet serre qui a été
nécessaire pour produire c'est bien
manufacturés le un taux de production de
gaz à effet de serre de la france
explose donc c'est si ces produits en
chine c'est parce que les salaires des
chinois sont encore plus bas que ceux
des français ce doux la délocalisation
mais c'est les consommateurs français
qui par leur achat contribue à faire en
sorte que la chine produisent du gaz à
effet de serre donc erreur d'analysé
total ce que disent les écologistes
c'est qu' il faut une taxe carbone aux
frontières et aux frontières de l'europe
c'est à dire que on va tenir compte dans
la façon dont on produit les produits
manufacturés ce qu'on importe
massivement de la chine on va en tenir
compte pour dire eh bien elle a produit
tant de gaz à effet de serre le le prix
carbone de la de prix carbone du gaz à
effet de serre ces 200 euros
tonnes et bien si le produit a produit
200 euros de gaz à effet de serre on va
on va les uns les impliquer dans le
produit manufacturé qu'on achète et
consomme en france pour pouvoir grâce à
cet axe pouvoir entraîner une transition
écologique et relocaliser notre
industrie c'est à dire recréer des
emplois dans notre pays et en même temps
dans la même main opérer la transition
écologique pour moins polluer la planète
et répondre aux enjeux du dérèglement
climatique
d'ailleurs sur lequel la france est
engagée en 2015 je le rappelle pour
laquelle elle ne tient pas ses
engagements
voilà après
pardon parmi les idées force et
également par par les verts il y a le le
fait d'eux des gens vrais c'est ce qui
s'est passé notamment à lyon jeudi
dernier c'était la rentrée scolaire
grégory douce et s'est rendu dans une
école la cour de l'établissement avait
été réaménagé cet été ou plutôt des
genres et pour favoriser les jeux à
activité mixte en finir donc avec cole
et traditionnels jeux de garçons face à
ce défi et il a été interpellé par un
élève le maire écolo de lyon regarder
les bad moi je voulais des cages de foot
et un vallon foule mais sauf comme par
hasard ya rien il ya des gaules a
adressé par quoi commencer ça pulse à
des copeaux de bois
après y'a rien il ya que des copeaux de
bois stéphane ravier une réaction à
cette déception de l'élève qui a vu
qu'il y avait plus de terrains de
football dans son école
un exemple évident flagrant comme quoi
les verts sont contre la nature s'il
vend 1 1 contre dans la nature la nature
humaine lucas recense les garçons les
filles c'est les filles les filles sont
libres de jouer au foot c'est le
souhaitent les garçons sont libres de
jouer à autre chose s'ils le souhaitent
mais il ya là une volonté les verts
d'imposer aux enfants de ne plus être
les garçons de ne plus être des filles
c'est un
versement de deux sociétés on veut on
veut complètement dénaturé les choses
dénaturer le nôtre quotidienne dénaturer
les petits garçons et petites filles
mais même les a et même les adultes
c'est un projet idéologique de la part
de gens qui rejettent notre modèle mais
le modèle naturel dans tous les domaines
ces gens sont dangereux ils sont
dangereux et il faut quand même se
rappeler qu'ils disent ils ont été élus
dans les grandes villes
c'est surtout en raison d'une d'une
abstention massive qui leur ont permis
d'accéder à ces municipalités
mais à à l'épreuve de l'heure de leur
gestion se rend vite compte que derrière
encore une fois ces discours de sauver
la planète de protéger la nature il ya
une volonté de transformation profonde
de notre société donc soit les français
quand même en soit en soient conscients
l'année prochaine lors des élections
présidentielles jacques boutault que
pensez vous ont parlé de d'imposer des
règles aux débuts de de ce débat est ce
que là ça va pas un peu loin dans les
écoles
non mais c'est à dire que
déjà encore une fois chez différences
d'analysé avec ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est que les comportements fille garçon
sont complètement culturel ils sont pas
innés ont leur gueule on leur donne des
modèles des modèles garçons des modèles
fit évidemment le modèle garçons c'est
celui qui prend l'espace est qui et qui
s'exprime avec avec force et violence et
le modèle filles c'est celui qui est
dans un coin et jouent tranquillement à
la coupée et fait pas de vagues sur
l'espace collectif c'est sa global mans
le modèle et on c'est pas naturel on met
les enfants selon leur sexe dans l'une
ou l'autre case l'idée du maire de lyon
c'est de dire que aujourd'hui il faut
laisser le libre choix justement aux
filles de faire du foot et aux engrais
aux garçons de jouer s'ils le souhaitent
et où est le problème si c'est
naturel de l'homme pas tellement l'autre
chose c'est ça le des genres âge mais il
faut 2 et la possibilité aux filles et
aux garçons de faire des choix libre et
éclairé sans leur imposer de modèle
merci beaucoup
non c'est l'un des mots principaux de
notre société et au bout du compte ça
crée notamment de la violence conjugale
extra conjugales et on le voit avec plus
de 100 fans qui se meurt par an sous les
coups de leur conjoint ça c'est une
réalité à sac une conséquence notamment
mais pas que la différence entre les
hommes et les femmes pour un même
salaire les femmes gagnent 20 % - voilà
tout ça ça fait partie de cette
inégalité qu'on n'impose aux enfants en
leur donnant des modèles et non pas en
leur donnant le choix alors le mot de la
fin très court pour vous stéphane ravier
sur ce sujet oui serez sujet du genre à
jouer
oui tu des genres est coupée une sorte
de rééducation à mao sans doute un des
inspirateurs idéologique des verts s'en
sont bien remontés à la surface
l'idéologie d'extrême gauche rééduquer
là des gens rage gris éduqués ou
réorienter la société vers un modèle
complètement idéologie qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la réalité
coûte que coûte de force s'il le faut et
c'est ce que démontre une fois de plus
le maire de lyon pour son délire
idéologique et hans attaque mais on sa
part comme le feu seulement comme l'anc
toujours fait les dictatures d'extrême
gauche on s'attaque aux enfants sous
couvert de bien-être on s'attaque aux
enfants à leur nature in et que vous le
vouliez ou pas parce qu'encore une fois
ils sont libres ou âgées moi j'ai pu
faire pratiquer du sport des enfants
dans les dents dans une école et j'avais
laissé libre choix aux enfants de
vouloir jouer au foot aux garçons et aux
filles certains ont souhaité rejoindre
les garçons pour jouer au foot oui je
leur est pas interdit et c'était très
peu nombreuses mais c'est ça la réalité
s'arrêter mais cette réalité mal vous
avez supporters monsieur par idéologie
merci beaucoup stéphane rail et on n'a
plus le temps malheureusement mais on
vous promet qu'on va suivre évidemment
la suite de cette primaire des verts
beaucoup jacques boutault d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur rt
france